pour les droits politiques est à côté de la plaque,
et ce qui est vraiment important,
c'est la distribution de nourriture, de logements,
d'éducation et de soins de santé.
« Donnez- moi la liberté ou donnez-moi la mort, »
c'est très bien si on peut se le permettre,
mais si on vit avec moins d'un dollar par jour,
on est bien trop occupé à essayer de survivre
et de nourrir sa famille
pour passer du temps
à aller essayer de proclamer et de défendre la démocratie.
Je sais que beaucoup de personnes
dans cette salle et dans le monde vont penser :
« J'ai du mal à comprendre. »
car le capitalisme privé et la démocratie libérale
sont considérés comme sacro-saints.
Je vous pose la question, que feriez-vous
si vous deviez faire un choix ?
Et si vous deviez choisir
entre avoir un toit au-dessus de votre tête
et le droit de vote ?
Ces 10 dernières années,
j'ai eu la chance de voyager dans plus de 60 pays,
dont beaucoup de marchés émergents,
en Amérique du Sud, en Asie,
et dans mon continent, en Afrique.
J'ai rencontré des présidents, des dissidents,
des législateurs, des avocats, des professeurs,
des docteurs et des citoyens lambda.
Durant ces conversations,
il m'est apparu évident
que grand nombre d'habitants des marchés émergents
croient qu'il se crée une séparation
entre ce que les gens croient idéologiquement
en matière de politique et d'économie en Occident,
et ce que les gens croient dans le reste du monde.
Comprenez-moi bien.
Je ne suis pas en train de dire que les gens dans les marchés émergents
ne comprennent pas la démocratie,
je ne dis pas non plus que, dans l'idéal, ils ne voudraient pas
choisir leurs présidents ou leurs dirigeants.
Bien sûr qu'ils le voudraient.
Mais je dis que, tout bien considéré,
ils se préoccupent plus de savoir
d'où va venir l'augmentation de leur niveau de vie
et comment leurs gouvernements vont les aider
plutôt que de savoir si oui ou non
le gouvernement a été élu démocratiquement.
Le problème, c'est que
c'est devenu une question très pertinente
car pour la première fois depuis très longtemps
se pose un vrai défi pour les systèmes idéologiques occidentaux
de politique et d'économie.
Ce système est incarné par la Chine. Au lieu d'avoir adopté
le capitalisme privé, la Chine a adopté le capitalisme d’État.
Au lieu de la démocratie libérale, la priorité n'est plus le système démocratique.
La Chine a également décidé de donner la priorité
aux droits économiques plutôt qu'aux droits politiques.
Je vous affirme aujourd'hui que c'est le système
incarné par la Chine
qui crée un élan parmi les gens
des marchés émergents comme le système à suivre,
car ils croient de plus en plus
que c'est le système
qui promet les meilleures et les plus rapides améliorations
des niveaux de vie le plus rapidement.
Si vous me le permettez, je vais prendre quelques instants
pour vous expliquer tout d'abord
pourquoi, économiquement, ils en sont venus à cette conviction.
La première raison, c'est la performance économique chinoise
des 30 dernières années.
La Chine a été capable de produire une croissance économique record
et à sortir un grand nombre de gens de la pauvreté de façon significative,
plus précisément, elle a diminué de façon importante la pauvreté
en faisant sortir 300 millions de personnes
de la misère.
Ce n'est pas seulement de l'économie
mais c'est également en matière de niveau de vie.
On observe qu'en Chine, 28 % des gens
allaient au lycée.
Aujourd'hui, on est plus proche des 82 %.
Donc au total, le progrès économique
a été assez impressionnant.
Deuxièmement, la Chine a su
grandement améliorer l'inégalité de ses revenus
sans changer la construction politique.
A ce jour, les États-Unis et la Chine
sont les deux plus grandes économies au monde.
Ils ont des systèmes politiques infiniment différents,
et des systèmes économiques différents,
l'un avec le capitalisme privé,
l'autre en grande partie avec le capitalisme d’État.
Pourtant, ces deux pays
ont le même coefficient de GINI
qui est une mesure de l'égalité des revenus.
Ce qui est peut-être plus troublant,
c'est que l'égalité des revenus en Chine
a récemment progressé,
alors que celle des États-Unis
a diminué.
Troisièmement, les gens des marchés émergents
observent l'introduction
de l'incroyable infrastructure légendaire de la Chine.
Il ne s'agit pas uniquement
de la construction de routes, de ports et d'autoroutes par la Chine
dans son propre pays --
elle a pu construire 85 000 kilomètres
de réseau routier en Chine
et dépasser celui des États-Unis --
mais si on observe des endroits comme l'Afrique,
la Chine a été capable d'aider à goudronner la distance
entre le Cap et le Caire,
ce qui représente presque 15 000 kilomètres,
ou trois fois la distance entre New York et la Californie.
C'est une chose que les gens observent et montrent.
Et c'est certainement sans surprise
que dans une étude Pew de 2007, lorsqu'on les a interrogés,
des Africains venant de 10 pays ont déclaré
penser que les Chinois
faisaient des choses extraordinaires qui amélioraient leurs moyens d'existence,
et par une large majorité, à 98 %.
Enfin, la Chine offre des solutions innovantes
aux sempiternels problèmes sociaux auxquels le monde doit faire face.
Si on voyage à Mogadiscio, à Mexico City ou à Bombay,
on verra une infrastructure en ruine, et la logistique
continue à être un obstacle de taille
pour la distribution de médicaments et de soins médicaux
dans les zones rurales.
Toutefois, grâce à un réseau d’entreprises publiques,
les Chinois ont pu atteindre ces zones rurales,
par le biais de leurs entreprises,
pour contribuer à la distribution de ces solutions médicales.
Mesdames et Messieurs, c'est sans surprise
que dans le monde, les gens montrent ce que la Chine fait ou dit,
« J'aime ça. Je veux ça.
Je veux pouvoir faire ce que la Chine fait.
C'est ce système qui semble fonctionner. »
Je suis également là pour vous dire
qu'on porte beaucoup d'attention
à ce que fait la Chine
d'un point de vue démocratique.
Plus précisément, il y a une incertitude croissante
parmi les gens dans les marchés émergents,
lorsque les gens croient désormais
que la démocratie ne doit plus être considérée
comme une condition préalable à la croissance économique.
En fait, des pays comme Taiwan, Singapour et le Chili,
pas seulement la Chine, ont prouvé qu'en fait,
c'est la croissance économique qui est la condition préalable
à la démocratie.
Dans une étude récente, on a prouvé
que le revenu est le déterminant le plus important
de la durée de vie d'une démocratie.
L'étude démontre que si un revenu par tête
est d'environ 1 000 dollars par an,
la démocratie durera à peu près huit ans et demi.
Si le salaire par tête
est entre 2 000 et 4 000 dollars par an,
on aura probablement 33 ans de démocratie.
Et seulement si le revenu par tête
est au-dessus de 6 000 dollars par an,
on aura une démocratie durable, qu'il pleuve ou qu'il vente.
Ce que ça nous dit,
c'est qu'on doit d'abord établir une classe moyenne
capable de tenir le gouvernement pour responsable de ses actes.
Mais peut-être que ça nous dit aussi
qu'on devrait se préoccuper de parcourir le monde
et forcer l'établissement de la démocratie
car au bout du compte on court le risque
de se retrouver avec des démocraties non libérales,
des démocraties qui, d'une certaine manière,
seraient pires que les gouvernements autoritaires
qu'ils cherchent à remplacer.
Les témoignages sur les démocraties non libérales
sont plutôt déprimants.
L'organisation Freedom House a découvert qu'alors que 50 %
des pays dans le monde sont à ce jour démocratiques,
70 % d'entre eux sont non libéraux
dans le sens où le peuple n'a ni la liberté d'expression,
ni la liberté de circulation.
Mais Freedom House nous apprend également
dans une étude qu'ils ont publiée l'année dernière
que la liberté diminue
chaque année depuis ces sept dernières années.
Ce que ça nous dit,
c'est que pour les gens comme moi
qui sont attachés à la démocratie libérale,
nous devons trouver une manière plus durable
de s'assurer que nous avons une forme durable
de démocratie, de façon libérale,
et qui trouve ses racines dans l'économie.
Mais ça nous dit aussi qu'alors que la Chine est près de devenir
la plus grande économie du monde,
chose qui est prévue
par des spécialistes en 2016,
la division entre les idéologies politiques et économiques occidentales
et le reste du monde va probablement augmenter.
A quoi ce monde pourrait-il ressembler ?
Eh bien, ce monde pourrait signifier
plus d'interventions de l’État et de capitalisme d’État ;
de plus grands protectionnismes des États-nations ;
mais également, comme je l'indiquais tout à l'heure,
des droits politiques et individuels
qui ne cessent de diminuer.
Il nous reste une question,
qu'est-ce que l'Occident doit faire ?
Je lui propose deux options.
L'Occident peut soit se battre soit coopérer.
Si l'Occident décide de se battre avec le modèle chinois,
et parcourt ainsi le monde entier
et continue d'essayer de forcer un programme
de capitalisme privé et de démocratie libérale,
ça va en fait avoir l'effet inverse,
mais ce serait également une position naturelle
adoptée par l'Occident
car, de nombreuses manières,
c'est l'antithèse du modèle chinois
qui est de faire passer en second la démocratie et le capitalisme d’État.
Le fait est que
si l'Occident choisit de se battre,
ça va augmenter la division.
L'autre option pour l'Occident est de coopérer,
et par là, j'entends
donner aux pays des marchés émergents
la souplesse de comprendre de façon organique
quel système politique et économique
fonctionne le mieux pour eux.
Je suis certaine que certains d'entre vous dans cette salle
vont se dire que c'est comme si on capitulait face à la Chine,
et c'est une façon, dans d'autres termes,
pour l'Occident de se mettre au second plan.
Je vous répondrai
que si les États-Unis et l'Europe
veulent rester influents, globalement parlant,
ils doivent peut-être envisager de coopérer
à court terme afin de pouvoir rivaliser,
et pour le faire, ils doivent peut-être se concentrer
plus agressivement sur les résultats économiques
pour aider à créer une classe moyenne,
et par conséquent être capable de tenir le gouvernement pour responsable
et créer les démocraties que nous voulons.
Le fait est
qu'au lieu de parcourir le monde
et de sermonner les pays qui collaborent avec la Chine,
l'Occident devrait encourager ses propres entreprises
à faire commerce et à investir dans ces zones.
Au lieu de critiquer la Chine et son mauvais comportement,
l'Occident devrait montrer
que son propre système politique et économique
est le meilleur.
Et au lieu de forcer la démocratie
dans le monde entier,
peut-être que l'Occident devrait prendre exemple
sur sa propre histoire,
et se rappeler qu'il faut beaucoup de patience
pour développer les modèles
et les systèmes qu'on a aujourd'hui.
D'ailleurs, le membre de la Cour Suprême des États-Unis, Stephen Breyer,
nous rappelle qu'il a fallu aux États-Unis
près de 170 ans
à partir de l'époque où la Constitution a été signée
pour qu'il y ait l'égalité des droits aux États-Unis.
D'aucuns affirment qu'aujourd'hui
il n'y a toujours pas d'égalité des droits.
En fait, des groupes déclarent
qu'ils n'ont toujours pas d'égalité des droits aux yeux de la loi.
A son apogée,
le modèle occidental parle de lui-même.
C'est le modèle qui nourrit la famille.
C'est les réfrigérateurs.
Ce système a envoyé un homme sur la Lune.
Mais le fait est que
même si des gens dans le passé
montraient les pays occidentaux et disaient :
« Je veux ça, j'aime ça. »
il y a désormais un nouvel élément
incarné par un pays, la Chine.
Aujourd'hui, des générations observent la Chine
et se disent : « La Chine peut créer de l'infrastructure,
la Chine peut produire de la croissance économique,
et on aime ça. »
Au bout du compte, la question que l'on doit se poser,
et la question que doivent se poser
sept milliards de personnes sur la planète,
c'est comment peut-on créer de la prospérité ?
Les personnes qui se sentent concernées et qui vont se tourner vers le modèle
de politique et d'économie
de façon très rationnelle,
vers ces modèles qui vont assurer
qu'ils peuvent avoir un meilleur niveau de vie
le plus rapidement possible.
Lorsque vous partirez tout à l'heure,
je veux que vous partiez
avec un message très personnel,
qui est ce que je crois
qu'on devrait faire en tant qu'individus,
et c'est d'avoir un vrai esprit ouvert,
ouvert au fait que nos espoirs et nos rêves
de créer la prospérité pour les gens dans le monde,
de créer et de creuser de façon significative le taux de pauvreté
pour des centaines de millions de personnes
doit se baser sur le fait d'être ouvert d'esprit
car ces systèmes ont de bons côtés,
et de mauvais côtés.
Pour illustrer,
je suis allée fouiller dans mes propres archives.
Me voici en photo.
Ohhh. (Rires)
Je suis née et j'ai été élevée en Zambie en 1969.
Au moment de ma naissance,
on ne délivrait pas de certificats de naissance aux noirs,
cette loi n'a été modifiée qu'en 1973.
Voici une déclaration du gouvernement de Zambie.
Je vous montre ceci pour vous dire qu'en 40 ans,
je suis passée du statut de non reconnue
à celui d'être humain qui se tient devant l’illustre public de TED
aujourd'hui, pour vous parler de mes opinions.
Dans le même sens, nous pouvons augmenter la croissance économique.
Nous pouvons diminuer considérablement la pauvreté.
Mais ça implique également
de regarder nos postulats,
nos postulats et les structures avec lesquels nous avons grandi
sur la démocratie, sur le capitalisme privé,
sur ce qui crée la croissance économique,
et ce qui réduit la pauvreté et crée les libertés.
Il nous faut peut-être oublier ces références
et commencer à regarder d'autres options
et garder l'esprit ouvert pour chercher la vérité.
Finalement, il s'agit de transformer le monde
et d'en faire un endroit meilleur.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)